[موسيقى]
نحن قلقون حقًا لأنك
تعرف
مع التأثير المركب
الذي تعرفه عن الرغبة في
تغير المناخ ونهاية الحرب في
أوكرانيا
التي
نراها مرة أخرى
أم تعلمون أن الصراع ينشأ عن
هجرة جماعية تحدث
ولا يستطيع العالم تحمل تكلفة هذه
[الموسيقى]
الآن ارتفعت الأسعار بشكل كبير في
جميع أنحاء المنطقة وأنك تعلم أنه
يؤدي إلى
عدم قدرة العائلات على وضع الطعام
على المائدة في المساء يمكنهم ذلك "  لا يمكنك
تحمل تكاليفها بعد الآن
[موسيقى]
برنامج الغذاء العالمي الذي تعرفه أو
تعلم أنه خطط لدعم 130 مليون
شخص هذا العام
تجاوزت ميزانيتنا الحد الأقصى بسبب
التكاليف المتزايدة التي تعلمون أن المتبرعين لدينا لا
يزالون داعمين للغاية ولكنهم بالطبع
نحن أيضًا في
مواجهة تحديات اقتصادية هائلة خاصة أنك تعرف
المانحين الغربيين بما يحدث في
أوكرانيا
[موسيقى]